nosotros ahora sabemos que es una
distribución de probabilidad y sabemos
que podría hacer una distribución de
probabilidad discreta o continuar
también aprendimos que es la función de
densidad de probabilidad así que ahora
empecemos a estudiar un par de las más
comunes así que digamos que tengo una
moneda y es una moneda justa que no está
alterada y la vamos a lanzar cinco veces
lanzar las cinco veces y voy a definir
mi variable aleatoria como el número el
número de caras que obtuve después de
cinco lanzamientos tal vez podrían ser
no sé quizás cinco monedas y lanzarlas
todas una vez y solo contar el número de
caras o bien tener una sola moneda y
esta misma lanzar las cinco veces y ver
qué es lo que sale de hecho eso no es
muy importante simplemente es para no
perder
y la idea o confundirnos pero bueno
entonces digamos que nosotros tenemos
solo una moneda y que la voy a lanzar
cinco veces solo para que no haya
ambigüedad con esto así que esta es la
definición de nuestra variable aleatoria
y como sabemos una variable aleatoria es
un tanto similar a una función que
asigna un número con algún experimento
así que vamos a pensar en las distintas
probabilidades que puede haber
pensemos la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 0 así que cuál es la
probabilidad de que no tuvieras caras
después de 5 lanzamientos y bueno
esencialmente es lo mismo que la
probabilidad de tener puras cruces
cierto esto es un pequeño repaso de
probabilidad entonces serían puras
cruces y cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener sólo cruces bien sería la
probabilidad de obtener cruz cruz cruz
cruz o sea cruz en cinco lanzamientos
cada probabilidad de cruz es un medio y
sería lo mismo que un medio a la quinta
que es un 32 hago
ahora cuál es la probabilidad puede
dedicar un poco de repaso de
probabilidad solo porque creo que es
importante para tener la intuición de
dónde vamos a llegar ahora de hecho
vamos a tener la forma de distribución
de probabilidad discreta y más adelante
veremos quizás continuas así que cuál es
la probabilidad de que obtengas una cara
durante cinco lanzamientos podría ser
que tuvieras cara cruz cruz cruz cruz o
bien que te salía cruz cara cruz cruz
cruz y así las diferentes formas y viene
esta primer cara que obtuviste podría
haber salido en cualquiera de estos
cinco tiros cierto de estos cinco
lanzamientos así que cuál es la
probabilidad de dicha situación bueno
pues la probabilidad de que obtengas una
cara es de un medio luego la
probabilidad de que te salga cruz es de
un medio entonces volveríamos a tener un
medio en cada una de estas posibilidades
entonces esta probabilidad sería una
situación particular
de hecho la probabilidad
de cualquier orden en particular de
caras o cruz va a ser un 32avos pues de
hecho son 32 posibles escenarios cierto
así que la probabilidad de esto es un
32avos entonces la probabilidad de esto
es un 32avos y son 5 situaciones como
éstas las que te pueden salir cara en
alguno de estos 5 lanzamientos así que
la probabilidad de que tengas
exactamente una cara es 5 por un 32 algo
que es igual a 5 32avos así que ahora
torna interesante lo siguiente así que
cuál es la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 2 lanzamos nuestra moneda cinco
veces y cuál es la probabilidad de que
me salgan exactamente dos caras ahora se
vuelve muy interesante así que vamos a
ver cuáles son las situaciones en las
que podríamos tener
cara cruz cruz cruz o bien cara cruz
cara cruz cruz y así vas poniendo las
posibles posiciones en donde vaya
saliendo cara y tendríamos o podrían ser
bastantes lugares diferentes por lo que
hasta puede volverse un poco confuso si
seguimos la misma lógica anterior por lo
que voy a pensarlo de una forma o de un
escenario analizando cada uno de los
siguientes casos pero de forma más
general y en cada uno de estos volvemos
a tener un 32avos de probabilidad cierto
pues cada una de estas caras tiene un
medio de probabilidad de salir y
multiplicadas cinco veces es un 32avos
por lo que esencialmente podríamos tener
cinco lanzamientos y vamos a elegir dos
de ellos en donde tengamos caras por lo
que podríamos imaginar que si tuviéramos
como si tuviéramos dos sillas y
dijéramos ok cualquiera se sienta en
esta silla sin importar el orden
teniendo como cara esto tiene sentido
pues no nos está importando el orden en
como salgan las caras sino si salen
exactamente dos caras y quizás tendrías
que mirar vídeos anteriores para tomar
un poco más de intuición con respecto a
la probabilidad y en los anteriores
hablo del teorema del binomio que quizás
se serviría para entender un poco más
esto y quizás tener más a detalle en las
cosas pero si piensas de esta forma el
coeficiente binomial comienza a hacerse
un poco más sencillo y tiene más sentido
entonces si pensamos que tenemos los
cinco lanzamientos cual lanzamiento
obtendrá la primer cara y bien son cinco
posibilidades cierto entonces deja hago
esto con un color diferente y son las
cinco posibilidades de cada una de estas
posiciones o cuál de los lanzamientos va
a hacerla
y bien después podrías preguntarte
cuántas posibilidades hay de que sea en
segundo lugar cara y bien pues el primer
lanzamiento utilizando lo que estuvimos
viendo aquí anteriormente suponiendo que
saldría en el primer lanzamiento
entonces para nuestro segundo
lanzamiento tendríamos cuatro diferentes
posibilidades de que cayera cara
entonces ahora multiplicamos por cuatro
y ahora pensando en esto cuando contamos
esto en realidad no depende del orden a
nosotros lo que nos importa es
simplemente cuantas caras obtuvimos no
en el lanzamiento que se obtuvo entonces
no estamos diciendo que sea la primer
cara la que nos importa o la segunda
cara pues aquí ambas son caras que es lo
que nos importa pudimos tener la primera
o la segunda cara o al final las caras
en realidad nos importa nada más que
sean exactamente dos durante los cinco
lanzamientos entonces vamos a dividir
entre
este producto que tuvimos arriba
entonces 5 por 4 es 20 y a dividirlos
sobre 2 nos da 10 entonces la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 2 es
un 32 a hbo por 10 que son las 10
diferentes formas de realizar estos
intercambios que el resultado es igual a
5 dieciseisavos ahora ya que tuvimos
este tipo de procedimiento vamos a ver
que hay diferentes formas de pensar esto
pues en regla no se está importando
cuáles son las distribuciones de
permutaciones y combinaciones entonces
ahora podemos pasar que esto es igual a
5 factorial sobre 3 factores del 5
factorial stewart a 5 por 4 por 3 por 2
por 1 y 3 factoriales 3 por 2 por 1 y
esto se cancela y nos queda este
resultado aquí simplemente hace falta
multiplicar por el 2
al que fueron las diferentes
combinaciones de caras que pudimos
obtener durante los 5 lanzamientos
entonces esta probabilidad de 132 szabó
nos resulta de aquí así que ahora
pasemos a nuestro siguiente ya nuestra
siguiente pregunta cuál es la
probabilidad de que x como variable
aleatoria sea igual a 3 y bien siguiendo
la analogía anterior tenemos 5
lanzamientos por 4 diferentes formas de
que haya la segunda cara y luego 3
diferentes formas de que esté nuestra
tercer cara y luego cuántas formas
diferentes puedo arreglar con tres
lanzamientos en general cuántos caminos
podemos hacer con estas tres cosas y
bien esto sería 3 factorial
es como si tomarás tres letras a b y c e
hicieran las diferentes combinaciones
que pudieran formarse con estos abc
acb se ve de ac/dc ahí me falta
finalmente
ve a
y son seis diferentes formas de
intercalar estos tres estas tres letras
entonces aquí lo que estamos dividiendo
es entre tres factorial es que es lo
mismo que tener seis entonces ahora en
este caso no nos importa el lanzamiento
sino la cara es por eso que tenemos tres
factores que es lo mismo que si
pusiéramos por acá cinco factorial sobre
tres factores al por dos factores y
estos tres factores de aquí abajo al
desarrollarlo nos queda igual a 3 por 2
por 1 se cancela con el de arriba éste
se convierte en dos al cancelarlo con el
de abajo y 5 por 2 es igual a 10 y
multiplicamos por el un 32avos de la
probabilidad de las caras entonces
nuestro resultado es igual a 5
dieciseisavos y pues lo siguiente va a
ser interesante observa que la
probabilidad de que obtengas tres caras
es la misma de que obtengas 2 y la razón
de esto bueno de hecho son muchas
razones en este caso pero si piensas en
la probabilidad
de obtener tres caras es la misma que
obtener la probabilidad de dos cruces
cierto es la forma contraria de obtener
la probabilidad y la probabilidad de
obtener dos cruces debería ser la
probabilidad de obtener tres caras y es
padre ver como las probabilidades se
comportan de esta forma y bien ya casi
lo logramos ahora fijémonos cuál es la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 4 y
bien podríamos utilizar la misma como
formulita utilizada anteriormente que
sea 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 sobre 4
factorial lo cual nos cancela el 4
factorial la parte de arriba y nos queda
simplemente 5 por un 32 a 2 lo cual nos
da como resultado 5 32avos y una vez más
observa como la probabilidad de tener
cuatro caras es exactamente la misma
probabilidad que tener una cara y esto
tiene sentido pues si quieres cuatro
caras exactamente es la misma
probabilidad de tener una cruz y dirías
bueno a dónde queda dicha cruz y bueno
son cinco diferentes posibilidades por
los lanzamientos para esto y en cada uno
de los escenarios se tiene un 32avos de
probabilidad y luego finalmente cuál es
la probabilidad de obtener x igual a 5
es como si tuviéramos puras caras lo
cual es igual a un medio por un medio
por un medio por un medio que es igual a
un 32 ago y otra forma de pensarlo es
pensar en las diferentes formas en que
puedes obtener cruz y cara en todos
estos experimentos los cuales son
diferentes circunstancias cierto y bien
ahora así que trabajamos esto estamos
listos para dibujar distribuciones de
probabilidad